Vamos a hablar
de su plan.
Vamos a hablar del plan Sánchez y vamos a descifrar
y explicarle a los españoles qué es el plan Sánchez.
Miren, el plan Sánchez es 1 plan
por el cual
el señor Sánchez se quiere perpetuar en el poder
controlando la tele pública,
las encuestas,
criminalizando a los constitucionalistas
y lavándole la imágenes a sus socios.
Eso es el plan Sánchez.
¿Cómo está haciendo este plan el señor Sánchez?
Muy sencillo, se trata de criminalizar
a todo el que no tenga el carnet del PSOE.
Se trata de
estigmatizar a todos los constitucionalistas
que hemos defendido la libertad,
la igualdad y la constitución durante muchos años,
y lavarle la imagen a Otegui en la televisión pública
y
pactar con los separatistas la Diputación de Barcelona
y quitarle el gobierno a ciudadanos y a UPN en Navarra
para pactarlo con Bildu,
con los nacionalistas.
Ese es el plan.
Y la pregunta es,
¿y con quién piensa llevar a cabo este plan?
¿El plan Sánchez?
Pues con su banda,
menuda banda, con Otegui brindando
con los nacionalistas en Navarra,
con los de mes en Baleares,
con los nacionalistas en la Comunidad Valenciana,
con podemos, llevando la economía de España.
Esos son sus socios de la banda.
Tiene 1 plan y tiene 1 banda.
Por tanto es mucho más importante votar hoy
en contra de ese plan que votar incluso de 1 gobierno
Sánchez, porque ese plan es 1 plan para 1 década.
Le hemos pillado,
señor Sánchez
Usted cuando llegó a la moción de censura
no lo hizo por la corrupción.
¿Sabe por qué no lo hice por la corrupción?
Porque le voy a hacer 1 pregunta
ahora que si me la contesta
me callo. Si usted dice
que el problema de la moción de censura
fue 1 caso de corrupción del partido popular,
usted VA a dimitir.
Usted VA a dimitir
si hay condena por los r al partido socialista.
Sí o no VA a dimitir
sí o no.
Contésteme,
por eso hay que oponerse al plan Sánchez.
Por cierto, ¿homenajes a terroristas?
Porque yo no quiero homenajes ni a Franco,
ni a maduro, ni a tarras.
Y en este país se hacen homenajes a etarras
porque ustedes lo permiten,
porque no hacen nada,
porque sus socios del PNV en el País Vasco no, no,
a ustedes no.
Qué vergüenza da ver esos homenajes, ¿señor Sánchez?
Porque señor Sánchez,
el lado correcto de la historia en este momento
no es estar con Bildu,
ni con pullemón, ni con Torra,
es estar con la Constitución y con la democracia.
Muchas Gracias